continuing to catch up on highly
requested Star Wars fan films today
Kenobi a Star Wars fan film from the
channel Jamie Costa before we hop into
this reaction I wanted to shout out
giant panda king
well what would we're not gonna do my
bit what bit where you say John you're
looking hot today and I say not as hot
as what's between the covers of Wookiee
erotica no I wanted to come from a more
sincere place this time but I was
feeling sexy so big we started getting
to know the people behind giant panda
king late last year they're very sweet
great human beings
I'm really excited we get to partner up
with them because I really mean it when
I say they're taking fandom and
creativity to another level
internationally gpk is best known for
the Empire strips back which is their
burlesque cabaret set in the Star Wars
universe I auditioned for it and for
some reason Greg got the callback are
you really that surprised sincerity well
the tour has been rescheduled due to the
pandemic you can still bring all that
sexy Star Wars goodness home with
Wookiee erotica viewer discretion is
advised for the next 10 to 15 seconds no
joke we actually read both of these
magazines cover to cover these are
modeled after a classic 70s pinup mags
and the attention to detail in these
things is nuts
they've got classic pinups centerfolds
erotic comics jokes party tips and a
whole lot more more more more women and
men but it's not all sexy with gpk they
also sent us this incredible Gotham 19
to 1939 book I read this whole thing in
the matter of two nights it takes the
characters and mythology of Batman and
reimagines them as part of
depression-era
American history and honestly if you go
to their website you'll see that this
stuff is just the tip of the gpk iceberg
so thank you gpk for sponsoring this
video I'll let you know once this
pandemic is over if I'm still available
to be in the burlesque show hit that
link in the description box and pin
comment to check out all that giant
panda King has to offer
[Music]
[Music]
Wow this on location it's like real six
okay
[Music]
[Music]
who the music's already incredible city
or like do they do a drone shot or is
this all stock footage
how long you gonna keep this up
you know you're watching over that boy
is more of a threat than anything we
knew you were here alcohol would oh in
origins
you think you're protecting it
[Music]
you're putting in a danger pin and not
just in
[Music]
no one knows in here but they will they
may not be able to connect the boy to
you but they could definitely connect
you to him
you can't avoid the empire the rest of
your life
[Music]
watch me
the Empire doesn't know we're here and
they never will
there's Felicity double agent
was just announced at the empire's in
the Outer Rim
the last transport leads to me
the Lucy
start war swing
[Music]
I love like the desolate deliberate
pacing
the way they do the focus it's a good
class I got on this
[Music]
you've
I hate sand gets everywhere
get rid of it
[Music]
Tuscon Oh anybody let's have her back
the worst time to place oh those Raiders
man they notice them
[Music]
[Music]
won't you please hide the boy looks so
familiar
[Music]
damage left his lightsaber behind
[Music]
[Music]
see how looks great oh cool that looks
great
[Music]
[Music]
Bridget's only half of the Empire
[Music]
where are they film this just the two
farm to land on no what seems a bit much
it is but it keeps us busy
a lot of things what is the point of all
of this a census we never had that
before it's for your own protection I
assure you it's important to know who's
coming don't shoot he's just a child
now I thought you said it was just the
two of you who is he is that what's it's
my dedication you don't need to see
their identification
[Music]
[Music]
hello there I'm the boy's uncle ran off
on me again getting too big for me to
keep up with what of his parents dead
down for some time now drinking money
not likely where you're from we're just
passing through very good at avoiding
questions search him
[Music]
I didn't think to hide the light same
[Music]
one that in the past that game not like
[Music]
we can go about our business
[Music]
Tamaki
[Music]
whoa
oh-ho-ho damn
Oh
[Music]
oh it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh I'm gonna do something cool without
realizing see the baby oh no this locket
Sam
since such a feeling glorious nipples
look how beautiful this is
it's just watching the show he's getting
[Music]
Imperial fred armisen
is everyone all right Shh he does sound
like you and McGregor man are we right
[Music]
I want
[Music]
thank you
Oh
[Music]
we're gonna report back to Germany with
cotton the fight with Sam people not the
records of this area are up to date and
that there is no interest yeah Daniel
Craig clean this stormtrooper you guys
know all the stormtroopers our celebrity
cameo and that you won't be needing a
blaster
[Music]
great job on using shots where you don't
have to show the vehicles moving save
yourself some money
[Music]
send it to Moscow
[Music]
after that overall it's great yeah
is it and some of the collider ones
doesn't he do you and McGregor on
collider that's the same guy I think it
is yeah
really I think so cuz i i i could be
mistaken but i know we've seen Jamie
Kosta do some deep faker some
impersonations in the past oh that guy
is Jamie Kosta yeah I believe so did not
pick up on that and God they got a good
cast in this overall though especially
the Imperial guys who did the music the
music was incredible yeah get to it
credits the music was great the Osmonds
that was good hey Andrew Garrett look
girly girl it sure that's the kind of
Star Wars name kick you know what I was
happy about oh my got a chance to shine
hmm you got a chance to be a badass or
like 30 seconds yeah it was uncle Owen
fans out there are gonna be so happy
feel vindicated for all those years of
fandom hmm
seriously though it's like the stern
uncle in a new hope joel edgerton plays
him an attack of the clones and it's
like he you see joel edgerton version of
uncle Owen when Hannah King goes back
home to find his mom he's and it's like
Anakin's like badass Jedi there's yes
funny cuz who watching Kenobi been in
this he was reminding me to [ __ ] Joel I
didn't yeah half the time um yeah let's
think of that - mm-hmm I completely
forgot he was in the prequels you're
going to enter geekdom match jump oh now
they don't wanna know if you
get that Star Wars is the one I most
don't to the better you get what about
Star Trek Star Trek but I feel like I
have more of an excuse not to nowheres
like Star Wars I'm like I've seen all
the films so I have to be able to know
where it's like Star Trek there's so
much there that is not like theirs I'll
study Star Trek and I'll get some
information there but I won't feel as
burnt by like missing some Star Trek
than I would Star Wars you know what
will upset me what if you get that
question on the internet you come and I
don't and I get some other obscure so
first question and I'm like unbelievable
John only knows that because we had a
discussion about this look out thanks
for helping me study yeah IndieGoGo
money well spent
yeah yeah and I mean that's especially
investing in like a short like that's
that's a you know a little bit of a risk
investment not to you know say that you
know you shouldn't have faith in the
creatives folks and stuff but yeah where
did they shoot this though cuz I love
that they went practical with it's like
shooting on location specifically I mean
there's like obvious shots where they
had to hide certain key moment like you
get the TIE fighters moving I think I
won't point you see the Star Destroyer
right in the background yeah I smoked
but you don't move
the horse will be with you that guiga
definitely qui gonn sweet quiz the
correct pronunciation for it I used to
think it was
that's why liam neeson didn't get a
chance to return because it's more like
lying nice okay as a stupid joke keep it
in the video
Jim Acosta playing Ben Kenobi here I
thought was great because in a new hope
when obi-wan first encounters Luke
Skywalker in the movie here's the name
obi-wan Kenobi and then the way Alec
Guinness does his performance it's like
obi-wan now that's the name I've not you
could tell there's this idea that he has
completely lost sight of that identity
of the Jedi obi-wan and has now just
embraced this wandering Nomad Ben Kenobi
and I love this short film for kind of
being that middle ground point where
he's a tortured soul
it's like Anakin's Darth Vader down and
he's stranded on this planet just
looking after Luke Skywalker and there's
a lot that's being said through the eyes
and the body language that I feel like
an audience viewer like ourselves can
pick up on or interpret at least you
know he's like looking after Luke
Skywalker but there seems to be this
sense of shame he inherited and again as
his Padawan and then ultimately probably
feels like you failed him looking after
Luke Skywalker Owen and Beru not wanting
anything to do with him no got a
recommending that he'd get out of here
as soon as Bob yeah I think he's just
more of a threat of just not feeling
wanted and it's being torn between
worlds in some ways a literal sense what
I loved about his performance
something's anything here necessarily in
the script that says it but I feel like
Jamie Kosta kind of had this portrayal
of potentially like borderline suicidal
Oh someone who just wants to kind of
give up on life like even when he cast
away a lightsaber I love that moment
because he's having to make a choice
there of how does he proceed when I
thought was cool about from a
storytelling perspective is
an adventure here but it's also like a
mix of a tone poem and a slice of life
like an episodic moment in the
in-between of Revenge of the Sith and a
new hope so I think that approach is
great and focusing on this moment in his
life his identity slowly transforming
not just from the outside as a cover-up
but within I think is a beautiful thing
yeah and I mean it had so much
atmosphere and going off of that point
you know I really like that first scene
in the cave between Ben and Owen because
yeah you get that sort of nuance that
there is like a tension being addressed
in a roundabout way obviously their
familial to some degree but because like
I know you're you're watching after our
kid and everything but yeah all these
concerns and it felt like it really did
a nice job of being within the Star Wars
world it's kind of like watching the
Mandalorian the way things move in or
captured a lot of the lensing and stuff
and I noticed too it looked like they
got some older lenses to use because
you'll have some of those shots where
the glass especially on the edges looks
a little blurred and rounded out those
look a lot more like older glass that
you would have been using on those
things and then yeah just the
conscientiousness of locations and how
those were used this location manager or
whoever did that for this is one of the
biggest unsung heroes probably because
it does really lend the credence and the
production value even though it's really
just about kind of getting out into that
middle of nowhere so you could do some
shooting yeah I love the poetry behind
all of this so much of it was just
communicated within its tone and I love
the trope in any of these like samurai
esque storytelling when warrior closes
his eyes just gets in tune with the
sentences and follows that and just
bleeds with feelings in terms of visual
storytelling it's great here they have
his little moments where he's trying to
use the Force
like manipulate the mind or he's just
pull what he needs to pull but he's not
able to fully get into it so he has to
get in tune with himself and in tune
with the force when he when he closed
his eyes there's more meaning to it than
just you know a badass sequence yeah
it's an arc here he's lost and now he's
found himself again and somewhere along
the way it's the one this made the
force feel like more tangible presence
again that does require an amount of
focus and effort because you know one of
the things people dog the recent movies
for is the force is everything it's
whatever you want it to be there's
elements of that throughout the series
to a degree but I thought they just the
physicality of representing the use of
the choice and yeah the emotional side
of that within the performances made the
force itself feel like a more if not
tangible just sort of lucid element of
this yeah I thought they left a lot to
just visuals without relying on dialogue
to really like you give just enough
dialogue to communicate moments because
there's so much tension here even with
Owen and Kenobi by the end of it when
they're looking at him doing his awesome
lightsaber ring the resolve that happens
in Peru saying thank you now he's
accepted and trusted even though by the
time I get to a new hope they're like
he's crazy yeah I just want a series of
these where it's just him going further
and further into adventure I think what
the ultimate dream would be for Jaime
Costa he stars in it produced it
co-wrote it and it's directed by Jason
saterland and I think it'd be a really
cool thing you know there's a lot of
like things happening with that obi-wan
show where I'm not sure which rumor to
believe if the production's all right
over I think would be a great thing if
they were able to do an episode of it
because they really captured a lived-in
experience of the world of Tatooine at
this moment in time like you said the
people on the Empire were great they
cast that British guy or at least the
guy did a British accent for the captain
character I thought was a really solid
performance guy plays oh and I thought
was a great performance Peru did a lot
with very little to do the bond dislike
young unspoken was what's that like
imprinted yeah and bad yeah I really
appreciated this one yeah it was it was
beautiful and its mood the entire time
and the productions I was great I got
nothing but praise for this these Star
Wars fan films man like I'm sure there
are a lot of great fan films of all
varieties but the Star Wars ones I've
most of them there are some people very
well deserving of a chance to make these
on a big scale because you want a small
scale look what they're doing
you know I saw fan films take place in
the in the world a marriage story which
were so good fan films that's a place in
the world of requiem for my dinner with
Andre fan films there's so many my green
book fan film is gonna knock your socks
really good like yeah I mean they just
pass in the background when they're on
the car yeah what would happen if there
wasn't racism anyway this is incredible
if you guys haven't seen it in full
video format and only here you're doing
yourself a disservice you should only be
here for the reaction part don't even
bother with the discus I know you're
talking to the audience talking to
YouTube listen your machine so check
them out subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification about the good
notify whenever we got a YouTube video
of me a locker would hit that like
button as well thank you to gpk for
sponsoring this video last but not least
let's do a page Pete Don I want to shut
this guy out specifically because Pete
Don is inspired writer he's setting out
to write like I think 32 books this year
it's absurd amount but the guy is
determined willing wildly creative he
also dabbles a lot in fan fiction
himself so watching someone who put fan
fiction together like this for Star Wars
I just wanted to encourage you to keep
on keeping on going after the fan
fiction more so in the horror side of
things use this as an inspirational tool
a lot of people are able to do this with
crazy sci-fi what's to stop you from
doing it with smaller scale horror
stories buddy just keep it going man
because I don't know many people who are
attempting to write as much as you right
now who are staying disciplined don't be
too hard on yourself if you start
falling behind because right now you're
shooting for the stars before you know
it you're gonna be landing on the moon
buddy so I love you math we've had a lot
of great conversations back and forth
I'm gonna read that draft you sent over
I just want to say I appreciate you dude
so thank you for being you keep on
writing your fanfiction
one day you'll see it made into a
private Vimeo link video one about us